as we have no ontological ground for
science itself
so
uh i'm very interested in exactly those
kinds of fundamental issues um
of
how
so for me
the problem of consciousness ultimately
is bound up with the problem of
intelligence the problem of making sense
but those are not just psychological
problems they are ultimately
epistemological ontological problems and
answering them together i think is
something well that's what i'm trying to
do with you here now i'm trying to get
um
how it is
that i'm trying to get your model of
ontology um and
where because you you do you have to
rely on judgments so like you went back
uh it's only a projection there's not
really a face there
that's a that's a positing of what's
real versus not real
and i'm trying to get at
is your account
of
rationality bound up with your account
of consciousness and intelligence it
seems like it is um and
doesn't that mean therefore that we have
to posit a certain kind of realness
to intelligence and consciousness the
way we have to for rationality because
rationality is how we determine what's
real in the world again i acknowledge
with you i'm not saying that i can do
that
you know with any kind of certainty but
nevertheless i have to be able to do it
in some kind of fashion i have to be
able to make judgments about real versus
not real in order to be generating the
kind of data we're both using when we're
talking here right now
so here's the argument in a nutshell
it seems that what's real depends on
what's rational and being rational seems
to in requires some kind of
self-awareness
some kind of consciousness and rational
seems to also uh require some kind of
basic ability to be
intelligent uh to
find certain things relevant rather than
others to pay attention to hear
to see the relevance of certain acts to
goals etc
and doesn't that mean therefore that
consciousness and
intelligence and rationality are just as
real
as anything else that we posit to be
real
the question is what is real and it's
it's a tricky question it's one question
yes uh
the property of ex being experientially
real requires i think that it needs to
be in our mind
so uh there is no way in which you can
wake up from the dream in your mind and
still exist because
out there in physics you are not
conscious neurons are not conscious
brains are not conscious physical
apparatuses are not conscious you need
to be inside of that dream
so if you ever transcend the dream
you will not be there the experience of
waking up is something that you dream
you can only
experience waking up while you are still
in a dream
and so you're not going to wake up in
some any kind of reality
and
there is this big question why there is
something rather than nothing it seems
to be hard to deny that something exists
and it's difficult to figure out how
it's possible that there is something
rather than nothing
and the easiest explanation that uh
the foundational physicists that i've so
far been
talked to have come up with is is
always the same
and rather than positioning that for
some funny reason something exists and
all the other things do not exist
uh maybe existence is the default
so
for some uh
funny reason the universe is not set up
as our intuition says that
basically nothing exists by itself by
default and then something needs to be
brought into existence somehow from
first principles the an easier
explanation is to reduce this depth is
to say that well just everything exists
and we have to now explain why something
don't seem to be the case
and so what would it mean for something
to exist in in my understanding for
something to exist it needs to be
implemented
and uh i would say that
many things only exist to an approximate
degree
so for instance um this cup here exists
to a very good approximate degree right
it's a certain idea that i can project
consistently in the universe that gives
me certain affordances and it's stable
for a pretty long time and are
well-defined conditions for the most
part for when this model falls apart and
i can no longer treat this as a cup
and
for instance when it breaks or when my
ability to interact with it breaks or
when the local physical continuum breaks
in such a way that the parts no longer
neatly assemble into a cup and so on
right so there are certain boundary
conditions where the cupness would no
longer hold but for the most part the
cup is very stable if i take rationality
as an object become slightly more fishy
or if i take my own personal identity as
an object
my own existence it becomes superficial
because
to which degree do i really stably exist
and to which degree is this a fiction
that i conveniently maintain to be able
to reason about myself over extended
time spans i think that i probably don't
exist in to the same
degree of solidity as the cup exists i'm
much more approximate i'm much more like
a voice in the wind blowing through the
mountains
my existence is much more virtual and
vague
and approximate than the existence of
the cup itself
if i go back to this notion of why there
is something rather than nothing and all
these things that can be implemented
exist that cup is implemented in physics
to uh to a
tighter degree than i am implemented in
physics i'm much more approximately
implemented
i would say that
what can be implemented are ultimately
finite automata it's also the only part
of mathematics that works that's
the implication of goodwill's discovery
that we have to go away from stateless
mathematics and instead what we get are
automata and we cannot define infinity
without running into contradictions in
the languages in which we do it
you mentioned that there are many
different ways to define logic and
different logics ultimately they come
down to the same thing that was also
part of this big discovery that we made
in the 20th century that all the ways in
which we can define logic and
computation and so on are
the same
they have all the same power
so the turing machine and the post
machine and the lambda calculus and the
combinators and boolean logic
and specific programming languages and
the different approaches to define
constructive mathematics turn out to be
equivalent
there are some
tight small elements at the boundaries
and so on where we could uh get into
debates but by and large uh they
all turn out to be uh
this mappings between these systems and
these mappings can all happen in
polynomial time or in constant time
and uh so it's not so bad
the logic can be solved if you look at
geometry uh there is not this question
oh my god there is not just euclidean
geometry but there's also non-euclidean
geometry these are not fundamentally
different it's just that the
non-occlusion geometry relaxes one of
the conditions which means the space in
which geometry takes place doesn't need
to be flat the space can have curvature
or it can be we can go beyond this and
it can be very irregular and so on and
it turns out that geometry is the
mathematics of too many parts to count i
think
so as soon as we have too many parts to
count uh the way in which we can perform
uh calculations is that we need to
identify operators that converge in the
limit which means if you have trillions
of parts and you add one more part the
result doesn't change perceptively in
any way right and this is uh when you
have something where you converge
approximately against infinity when you
have approximate continuity
and the set of operators that converge
in the limit when you have too many
parts to count this is practically what
we mean by geometry
so it's a particular way to model worlds
that are made of too many parts to keep
track of the individual parts
and of course our brain is largely
confronted with the world at such a
level where there are too many atoms to
count too many molecules too many people
to count
too many
dollars to count and so on and so we
treat them as continuous values and we
look at the limit dynamics and we have
geometric models